[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
Alex Mohler and I'm excited to be
talking with you about our topic and
today we're going to be talking about
Improvement how do we improve our pieces
and we're going to be focusing on a few
in particular the ones we're going to be
looking at are all the pieces that
attack in a straight line so the Rooks
the Bishops and the Queen
um the night we're going to kind of
touch on
um and obviously Kings and pawns will
play a role but we're really going to
talk about how can we improve these
pieces
and put them to the best use so
something that's really important when
you're playing a game of chess is to
think about one developing right in the
beginning you want to get your pieces
into the game you don't want them
sitting on the back row but then as
positions develop and change it's
important to recognize where do your
pieces actually belong and how can we
maneuver them into their best possible
squares
um
so we're going to look at a bunch of
examples tonight and we're going to
really focus on the ideas of long
diagonals for the Bishops and open files
for the Rooks and then the queen kind of
a blend of those two
so here's a general example of
improvement this is a we're going to be
looking at a lot of different Grand
Master games
and this was a really useful game to
demonstrate this kind of idea
we have a Sicilian Defense and there's a
little bit of unusual kind of move order
choices in the beginning but eventually
we're going to get into a fairly normal
position
and I'm going to skip ahead a bit until
we get to a really interesting position
something I do want to note again we're
not really going to talk too much about
the knights today in terms of how to
improve them but the general thing with
the Knights is you want to find places
where we're not going to be easily
attacked by pawns
um
and you want them stuck in the enemy
position more centralized but something
that's just very kind of a quick and
dirty rule for the nights it's really
helpful for me is whenever you identify
a square you want the night to go work
backwards so for example if we're saying
well I can't put my net on C3 in this
position
where should my night go maybe it wants
to go to B5 and maybe there's some
threads over here maybe it wants to
eventually end up on C2 where it can
support us in the center or even perhaps
a B4 Pawn push and so we'll pick those
squares and be like okay how could I get
to this Square well I could go to A3 and
then I could get my knight from there
and you can kind of work backwards makes
it a little easier but okay so we have
this game
and we get to this position
and it's White's turn to move and white
decides to do a few kind of improving
moves very quickly so first I see this
Knight that had done a job on C2 right
white wanted to maybe
potentially push forward here but now
without a c pawn and with our d-pawn
locked up this Knight isn't really doing
anything
and so white decides that it's going to
improve this Knight and it says where
would this piece like to be what are
some of the good squares
you can always move it here but then
we're just trading and maybe that
doesn't really accomplish too much
we can leave it where it is and try and
put pressure here but black is pretty
well defended between the queen and the
bishop so this Knight really isn't doing
too much and uh the player with white
here kovalenko decided
this Knight would be really annoying if
it was on C5 it would attack this bishop
all of Black's pawns yeah and uh for
dessert right as I was saying that C5
seems juicy right it's attacking this
bishop there's no pawns that can kind of
push it out of the way and this dark
squared Bishop is going to have a harder
time trading for it because there's so
much in the way you also probably
wouldn't want to trade this bishop
anyway it needs to defend the king
so how do we get to C5 well let's work
backwards uh candidate squares well our
pawns are on D3 and E4 looking at enemy
territory generally isn't helpful
because it's going to be hard enough to
get there anyway
A4 is covered by this Pawn
so B3 is really the only place we can
get there and how can we get to B3 well
again C5 obviously but that doesn't help
us A5 also not really helpful but we
look and notice oh wait A1
and my knight actually can connect to A1
so uh White spends the next three moves
having seen that they want to put the
net on C5 playing Knight and one if you
looked at this move in isolation this
would look so silly the knight in the
corner that's like the worst place for
it you're not developed you only control
two spaces but we're thinking longer
term right we're thinking about where do
we want this piece to go black continued
with A5 Knight B3 clean B6 and Knight C5
defended by our Rook here
and White's Knight has transformed from
something that on C2 really wasn't
impacting the game to now it's a really
good Potential Threat right we have
potential Forks on D7 this bishop might
be a little loose in some variations uh
this Knight's just kind of a monster on
C5 it's a significant Improvement
we're going to see a similar Trend later
on in the game so black plays rook d8
and a few more moves continue
um did white think C5 before 93 before
Knight A3 so that's all the way in the
beginning you might have eventually
considered that but it's too hard and I
can actually jump back in time real
quick to that position so this was the
position in that point in the game when
Knight A3 was played you sometimes have
to wait and see how your opponent is
going to develop and maneuver their
pawns it's a little too hard to predict
and they can often like play against you
like if the idea was specifically to get
this Knight to C5 I mean one right now
sure maybe we can attack this Pawn but
black could also if we spend a lot of
time making that plan say we say Okay I
want to attack C5 so an easy way to do
that would be to go to B3 and then we
can go to D2 and get that way
well that's all well and good and then
maybe they just play Pawn to B6 and
defend and they go for a whole different
plan that invalidates our idea so you
don't want to think too far in the
future that your opponent can kind of
they haven't made a commitment
um but once it's a more settled position
like in this position it's a lot harder
to stop us getting Knight to C5
um there's not I don't really think
there's a good way to do it with this
planet it's just very quick maybe they
could play here but
oh our Bishop always could potentially
take we have our Queen defending so
never mind they don't really have a way
to stop it
so you want to look for how committed
your opponent is to the position and if
your plan of improvement uh if they have
any way they can very easily nullify it
and just make you have wasted a bunch of
time it's a really good question
okay but let's jump back so we get the
Knight to C5 a few more moves continue
both sides kind of slowly improving
their pieces slowly improving the
position
and again white takes a look at their
position and let me ask you of all the
pieces here in White's Camp which one do
you think is the least impactful which
of White's pieces is doing the least is
contributing the least for our kind of
army
and our general kind of attack or
defense or our general plan
which of these pieces and not the pawns
the pieces so we got the two knights the
two Bishops the two Rooks are the queen
and yeah somebody's already a little
ahead
uh don't drink and drive doctor uh but
yes So the plan is this bishop on D1 is
really contributing nothing this Rook is
well placed on the open file this queen
is nicely looking at the opponent's king
this bishop is kind of holding
everything together but potentially one
day if this pawn moves it can jump into
H6 so it seems reasonable
and this work as well on the
file might help support some kind of
Pawn pushes towards the king our Knight
obviously is really good so the one
piece here that's not really pulling its
weight is this bishop and the question
is okay where would I like it to go well
it doesn't really seem like it can do
anything this way maybe we can look at
getting it here but white decides
instead of having to maneuver my knight
somewhere because that's already going
to ask a lot and then I have to waste
time moving it back
instead white plays this really nice
idea Bishop to C2 to B1 to A2 in order
to get on this really nice diagonal it's
not quite the long diagonal but it's
very close and just slowly improving
there's no threats in the position white
needs to be concerned with and so we
have time to join the attack
and using this combination of this
beautiful net on C5 and this bishop
white actually is able to uh win this
game I'll show you really quick what the
game looked like Rook to A7 G4 so arcing
is pretty safe even though the pawns
were exposed there's not any attack
against us so we can afford to push all
of our pawns to them King to h8 getting
out of this dangerous diagonal but it's
just not quite enough
E5 looking to break everything open
and F takes Knight back to E4 and
Intermezzo attacking the queen so the
queen moves and now we recapture
and Knight takes C5 and instead of
recapturing the Knight we have the
really nice knight from E to G5 making a
Checkmate threat also this Knight's just
controlling a lot of very important
squares
okay Knight takes F3 this is check the
recapture H6 stopping the Checkmate
threat but white sees a really beautiful
tactical sequence I'm not going to ask
you to look for it if you want to you
can pause and always look at any
position you want assuming you're not
watching this live I guess you could and
then you'd have to refresh but
um but yeah if you're watching this
later on YouTube or on a twitch
recording please feel free to always
pause at any of these moments but in the
game white played Knight to F7 check
this is forking the king and queen so
black has to retake
Rook takes F7
Queen to E8 and Rook takes E7 the kind
of the point of this whole maneuver
and it looks like this Rook is not
defended enough it's only defended once
it's attacked twice but the problem is
after Rook takes
Rook takes C8 pinning the queen to the
king deflecting the queen away from this
Rook
Queen takes and we win The Rook back now
we just have two Bishops versus blacks
one and black played a few more moves to
try and cause some problems Queen to C2
but white has an answer to this fork in
Queen takes E6 defending the bishop and
threatening Checkmate so there is no
time to take on D2
Queen to D1 check and Bishop to E1 white
has successfully defended their position
and Checkmate is basically Unstoppable
uh White has yeah is defending just
everything this queen is a monster it's
on this beautiful diagonal and white was
able to take advantage of improving
their pieces
so that's kind of the the general idea
here of improvement again not expecting
you to see everything from those Grand
Master games but I think as we go
through it'll be helpful to understand
one where are we going to first identify
and which piece of ours is not
contributing and also saying how can we
put pieces in really nice spots and
again specifically looking at the
Bishops and the queen and the Rooks so
we're going to start with the Bishops
so the long diagonals are often where
the Bishops want to be and there's
really two long diagonals in the game
and they are the ones from each corner
to the other corner
the reason these are so good for the
Bishops is because they control one
critical Central space
two the Bishops can be sitting pretty
far back and looking all the way in at
their opponent's territory and also
especially if you notice long diagonals
usually will intersect where the Kings
is castled whether it's kingside or
queen side
um
so these are excellent for placing the
Bishops either in the center but you
don't even need to you can also place
them kind of in this fianchetto style
something more uh close to home
and it's also really good for building
batteries right so we want our pieces to
work together in harmony the queen can
work team up with either Bishop either
in front or behind to make a battery
where both of them are attacking the
same line and the Rooks can team up with
each other or with the queen
the two Bishops sadly cannot team up in
the same way because they are on
different colors but the fact that they
color cover different complexes also
makes them valuable
now this is an opening example that a
lot of people will probably be familiar
with at least the idea of it's quite
popular at the beginner levels this is
actually called the Danish Gambit so
after E4 E5 white plays D4 and this is
going to be an extreme example but in
this opening white gambits away
three Pawns in in exchange for this
black pond so we're going to be giving
up material and that's what a Gambit
actually is it's just when you're giving
up material in order to gain some
positional advantage that will hopefully
serve you later on to either win back
more material or Checkmate the king or
something along those lines
so uh after black takes this Pawn white
does not recapture white instead plays
C3 giving up another pawn and again
white does not recapture they play
Bishop C4
and this bishop is occupying a very nice
diagonal again it's not the long
diagonal but it is still very good and
this one in particular is really
dangerous for black because of the F7
weakness these two pawns on the F files
are very weak because only the king
defends them so having a piece that can
kind of laser focus in on that weak
Target is going to be really helpful
black accepts our third Pawn this is
probably a bit too much probably better
for black not to take all of these and
just start developing because even
though
um
we they lose or sorry even though white
loses two pawns net
this is a really dangerous position you
can see our Bishop on B2 occupies the
long diagonal this bishop on C4 attacks
the weak F7 square and kind of
harmonizes with this B2 Bishop to just
put a massive amounts of pressure on the
king side for black so this is already a
really dangerous position objectively
probably black is slightly better but
it's still very dangerous and it's quite
easy for black to fall into a trap for
example say something like Bishop to B4
check Knight to C3
Knight to F6 black is now trying to
cover their bases in development get
their King castled and just start
fighting because if they can trade a
bunch of these pieces then the material
difference is going to add up even more
here white plays Knight to E2 probably
not the best move but it is setting a
very clever trap
because black has pinned this Knight to
the king so the Knight cannot move and
if you remember our video on pins one of
the things about a pin is a pinned piece
does not protect right so this Knight
normally would be protecting E4 but
because it is pinned it actually cannot
move so if something were to take E4
like this Knight we cannot recapture
with our Knight It's actually an illegal
move because then our king would be in
check
unfortunately for black this is all part
of light's plan White Castles Knight
takes Knight takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes and black has managed to win
another Pawn meaning they're up three
points in this whole position but
they're now too weak to actually stop
our threats our Bishops are two
monstrous on these diagonals and uh in
the game black castles King side here
but because there is zero development
and they walk white right into where our
pieces are attacking they probably
Castle in order to get off of this
dangerous open file right if they don't
our Rook is going to cause them quite a
serious problem as well so they Castle
but unfortunately in this position we
can harmonize our Bishops and our Queen
to find a winning attack so see if you
can find the best move here for white
again as always feel free to pause the
video if you are watching this later and
if you're here live as always in the
classroom or on on the stream feel free
to leave a comment with your idea so
what should white do here to gain the
advantage of their beautiful developed
Bishops and Black's lack of development
I think there are two moves that seem
fairly obvious
but one of them is winning and the other
one is still probably about even
so see if you can find the best move
anyone have any ideas
Queen D5 suggested Queen D5 is not a bad
move uh
mantari D I'm not not sure exactly to
pronounce her name but so the queen D5
is nice we're kind of making a battery
with this bishop the only downside is
the pawn we're attacking this F7 pawn it
used to be the weak one now that black
is castled The Rook is an extra Defender
so F7 is actually a little bit safer
um so D5 is not quite strong enough just
because black is a little bit defended
there
um
for dessert Queen to G4
is the right idea Queen 2 D4 also looks
tempting
because both of these moves G4 and D4
both attack this Pawn on G7
which is only defended by the king and
so we're forming a battery but G4 is
better because if we go to D4 right away
black can try and survive with Queen to
F6 and we'll have a nice attack into
their Castle but we're also still down
material so we have to prove that we can
earn it so if we start with Queen to G4
this queen of six move just isn't
possible because it's just a free Queen
um and there's actually no good way for
black to proceed here
they can't block or attack with the
f-pawn because our Bishop is pinning It
To The King
and if they play something like G6 we
can as Furniture said switch over to D4
now Queen F6 is not a move because the
pawn does not defend and there's no good
way to stop Queen to G7 there's actually
really the only ways to play Queen to F6
sacrifice it and then you only just
delay it and move
so again a pretty extreme example
um maybe objectively not the best way to
play but a very strong assertive way I
didn't start exactly with the Danish
Gambit but I started with similar ideas
with the scotch Gambit of trading a
little bit of material for some rapid
development attacking chances and
especially with these Bishops like this
it's quite a monstrous thing to face so
Bishops on these long diagonals you
always want to keep an eye out for
um
one of the kind of additional benefits
that can be really helpful
both for your game to play but also to
avoid is the idea that the bishop and
the long diagonal can sometimes be hard
to see if that makes sense like pieces
kind of sitting out in the center are a
little more obvious but a bishop just
fan kettled off to the side is not so
obvious sometimes it's easy to overlook
its attack
and there are a lot of traps
based around this kind of idea so one
for example comes out of the grab
opening this is not something I would
recommend you play but it is instructive
for this example it starts with one to
G4 which I believe is objectively the
worst move like in plan turn one again
would not recommend but there are some
tricky ideas so let's say black plays D5
saying well you put a Pawn on G4 I would
like to take it for free and punish you
white plays Bishop G2 and black happily
eats the pawn and now white continues
with this tricky idea of Ponto C4
and if you're not careful you might be
thinking oh well you gave up one Pawn
maybe you're just not a good player
you'll give up a second Pawn the problem
here
if you have not spotted it yet is that
white actually can play Bishop now takes
B7 on this very long diagonal the pawn
was pinned in a way to that square so by
taking we are now trapping our Rook
after the bishop takes there's nothing
we can do to save this Rook it can't
move and
the bishop has it trapped so keeping out
an idea or keeping an eye out for this
type of idea can be helpful
what's funny is in this particular
position black is actually still better
after Knight D7 and takes takes black
has a slight Advantage here uh so yeah
this is a Sanders approved trap but
still this is not something I would
recommend playing because it's just it's
very bad but the Trap is legitimate this
idea just not in this particular opening
so some other examples where that might
come in
one that's maybe a little more familiar
is in the Queen's Gambit this is a very
old trap but for people who aren't
familiar with Queen's Gambit D4 D5 and
then C4 and it's a Gambit because again
we are sacrificing some material for an
advantage
there's nothing defending this Pawn but
the idea is often if you take then we're
going to have more control in the center
your d-pawn was doing an important job
controlling the center and we can later
play E3 and win this Pawn back
and one of the reasons the Queen's
Gambit isn't really a Gambit is because
it's actually problematic to try and
hold on to this Pawn
for example let's say you play B5 and
say okay well now you just can't take it
I have an extra Pawn so shouldn't black
be better well maybe but there are some
problems if Pawn to A4 black now has a
bit of an issue
if you play Pawn to A6 I believe we will
just take and you can't take back
because your Rook will hang
again we've kind of opened a file so we
will talk more about the open files and
the Rooks in a moment
so some people will say well I can't do
that so I'm just going to play C6
but now we can still take
and it is white to move and punish black
for trying to hang on to this extra
material
what should white do in this position
audio 11 welcome in welcome in long time
chess fan we are glad to have you any
idea for this position white to move and
black has tried to punish or sorry black
is right too yeah punish white for
giving up this C Pawn by holding on to
it but unfortunately this is not going
to work and uh Emily Emil I'm not sure
exactly how to say your name in the chat
has spotted it a few other people coming
in right after the problem here is Queen
to F3
did this as black in a 15-minute game
well if you haven't seen this idea it
can seem well why would you just give me
a pawn the problem is now our Queen
enters this long diagonal and actually
funny enough there's no way to save The
Rook here even though we have so many
pieces there's nothing you can do if you
block with a knight it's not defended if
you block with the bishop it's not
defended same with the queen there's
nothing we can do to defend this Rook
so we're just going to lose it
it is quite unfortunate you can I guess
you could play like Bishop here in the
night over and lose the bishop instead
but you are losing some material because
of this weakness on the long diagonal
now we're going to look at a few
well I'm actually going to skip ahead so
I have some examples from games from
long diagonals but we're going to switch
to open files because I want to make
sure I kind of cover all my bases here
and then we'll come back and look at
some master games with examples from
both
so keep all the long diagonal
information and the Bishops in your mind
but now I want to talk about open files
so Rooks belong in the open files this
is something you may have heard this is
kind of an axiom in the Chess World but
you might not understand what the idea
is at the most basic level
well before I explain what is an open
file if you're not familiar with the
terminology an open file just means so
the files are the vertical columns on
the chessboard they're labeled a through
H the ranks are the horizontals
so it's one through eight all these
horizontal lines and Rooks belong in the
open files so an open file is any
vertical column any file where there are
no pawns from either side so in this
case white has a rook on the open E file
black has a rook on the open D file
if there is just one Pawn on a file that
is a semi-open file so this Rook on B1
is attacking our Pawn on B7 but there
are no white Pawns in its way this would
be a semi-open file and we can imagine
if our Rook on d8 was on B8 instead it
would also be on a semi-open file just
defending
and then a closed file not a term we use
really that often but it's anyone where
there are Pawns of both colors in the
way Rooks really would like to be on the
open files and perhaps you can
intuitively understand why because it
gives them a lot more Mobility they can
make lots of threats they can invade and
if they're stuck behind pawns it's not
so good if they're attacking cons on
semi-open files that can be okay but
usually open files is going to be the
best
which means we can look at positions
like this I believe I've looked at this
example before in my um
like kind of introduction to the Rooks
but this is useful as well here it's
white to move and play the best move
even though the position is totally
equal in terms of the material
so both sides have eight pawns we have
not traded any yet and both sides have
two Rooks in there King but because it's
white to move and because of the
particulars of this position white
actually has a nice Advantage if you
find the right idea
and uh fan B Welch not sure exactly
again if that's how I say your name I
apologize to anyone if I mispronounce
how you intend your name uh alphazir
loves open Bishop diagonals I actually
have an example of a game that Alpha
zero used that we might take a look at
in a moment
but in this position
white to move how can we
and if you're having some trouble with
this the basic idea is we have our
pieces and we want to improve them so
with the first example we looked at the
night kind of traveling around the board
to a 2 or sorry to A1 into B3 into C5
and then the bishop rerouting slowly
sometimes improving a piece means moving
that piece into a better position and
sometimes it means moving other pieces
to create room
in this case as a
mamaramu again apologize if I
mispronounce has the right idea by
taking this Pawn we are improving our
Rook on E1 by attempting to open this
file and black is actually in a bit of a
bind here if you don't take back then I
just want a pawn
but the computer actually says the best
move is to play E5
accepting that they have given up this
Pawn we can try and play C4 and hold on
to it potentially or maybe make other
threats but black says opening this file
is too dangerous they are willing to
give up the pawn
um if you just take with the Rook well I
just take this one back
and if you take with the pawn
then I invade so Rooks belong on open
files but they also belong on the
seventh or the second rank so the
horizontal line one space above the edge
of the board you want to be on the one
closer to your opponent because that's
going to be the attacking one what is
the reason for this well it's kind of
two-fold one the pawns all start here
and so usually there's going to be a few
pawns left on this file we can already
see if we play Rook D7 we are attacking
this Free Pawn on G7 and this uh Pawn
near the King on C7
the other reason is with enough pressure
and especially out from other pieces you
can keep an opponent's king locked into
this rank which can be really
unfortunate right maybe you can set up
back rank threats or you can just have a
winning King and pawn end game where you
can keep their King locked away long
enough to activate yours and win so
using the open files to invade your
opponent's position on the seventh or
the second rank is a very effective
strategy just to kind of see how
dangerous this can be
black let's say needs to defend this
pawn and plays Rook to G8
we now can double our Rooks this is a
battery right we have two pieces that
attack in the same direction on the same
line
and this stops our opponent from putting
a rook on E8 to challenge us right
before they would have loved to try and
challenge us and stop us from having
total dominance of this file now it's
too late if you do this now I will just
take and win
so you cannot do that so instead let's
just say again they make another move
something like
maybe Rook yeah just to f8 it's hard to
say what exactly is good for black kid
because we're so strong
and we can slowly try and improve maybe
something like Rook D7
and they defend
and we now invade with two Rooks on the
seventh rank again black has not been
playing optimally here in this example
but these two Rooks now this double
Brooks on the seventh rank are basically
Game ending even though the material is
equal here the computer evaluates at a
low depth that this is plus seven for
whites more than a rook almost as much
as a queen just because of where our
Rooks are placed in comparison to our
opponents ours are attacking all of the
valuable squares and creating major
threats against the king and our
opponents are stuck defending on these
closed files
so that's the idea with open files now
let's jump back and we're going to look
and see how long diagonals and open
files can work together or independently
to gain a lot of pressure
and I mentioned the alpha zero game so
I'm going to show I'm not going to show
the whole game it's a very long game but
a few years back Alpha zero played
stockfish in a whole bunch of games and
this position is actually one of my
favorites
I'm not going to ask you to predict the
moves of these super computers but in
the game stockfish played Knight to D7
it looks like it's sacrificing the queen
but it's also discovered attacking the
queen and we can notice that the
position is not equal materially black
has three points Advantage actually
similar to the Danish Gambit example in
the first case but look at White's
Bishops these two pieces are just
disgustingly monstrous they are
attacking right through the enemy camp
hitting incredibly relevant squares um
White's rook and queen are also quite
active while blacks are a little more
passive
so white does not want to trade material
here they have an incredibly
advantageous attacking position and so
light retreats
Rook to F6 and black is now giving up
this Rook for a bishop and white says no
way my Bishop is way more valuable on
the long diagonal than your Rook white
just pushes this Pawn
Queen to E7 unpinning so now the Rook is
going to move if you don't take it
but instead stockfish or sorry Alpha
zero decides I'm not going to take it
with the bishop I'm going to take it
with the Rook because my Bishop is too
valuable
okay so Knight takes
Pawn to F5
using the second Bishop to start
striking at these Pawns in coordination
with our Rook on the semi-open file
black plays Queen to E3 desperately
trying to trade some material to lessen
the power of this attack
and white now sees it can simplify into
a winning end game so Place Pawn takes
pawn queen takes Queen we have an
Intermezzo before we recapture the queen
we take with check
King to F7 excuse me Rook takes Queen
Knight takes Pawn because if you don't
I'm probably going to promote or trade
for something worse
so Knight takes pawn and Bishop takes
Knight and in the resulting position
white is up
in material we have our Bishop pair
against one bishop and even though black
has two extra pawns one of them is
doubled this bishop is basically a tall
pawn and white went on to win this game
uh quite soundly so again uh the point
is less about understanding the precise
moves and the play at this level but
more just to see how powerful these
Bishops and Rooks when they are well
placed can really be at digging into
your opponent so putting the Bishops on
the long diagonals pointing them towards
your opponent's castle and they're
important pieces and having Rooks
fulfill a similar role
um okay
let's look at a few kind of
examples here
this is kind of a really fun example
because this from comes from a grand
master game where both Players missed
the best move
um
and
white here plays D4 Knight F6 C4 E6 we
have a nimso Indian defense G3 looking
to put the bishop on the long diagonal
as we said this is very strong
C5 kind of invading in the center D5 and
this is all kind of Fairly normal
opening Theory
B5 pressing forward on the queen side
now that this there's not a lot of
control here
Bishop G2
putting the bishop online and
potentially attacking this Rook D6 to
stop it
and I believe we have a trade of Pawns
here trade trade
Knight to H3
again thinking
white here is not making the obvious
move Knight to F3 they have some ideas
of where this Knight wants to belong so
they're moving it here first
uh Bishop D6 to stop the pawn from
invading further into the position and
discovered attacking a rook
and castle and in this position White
made a mistake they missed something and
just decided to Castle and black who was
no less than Gary Kasparov right a
Grandmaster at the ultimate levels of
play a world champion uh also castled
but there was a move here that's like
plus five just crushing so see if you
can be a little better than Kasparov now
we have the benefit of hindsight and
knowing that this is a puzzle that can
be solved but see if you can find a move
that both casparov and his 2700 rated
opponent failed to find in their game
how can we punish white for simple play
and yeah fur dessert has the right idea
Bishop to E5
taking the long diagonal attacking The
Rook
and take a close look at this position
and you realize
this work is trapped I can't move
all the pawns are gone you can't block
night blocks I take it if Bishop blocks
I take it
this Rook is just trapped there's just
nothing that
white can do here to save the rook and
both of these players just missed this
move it's kind of a remarkable but again
something to tell you that you know even
really good players can make mistakes
and you always want to keep an eye out
for potential misplays even from really
good opponents by taking advantage of
putting your pieces on really good
squares
um
if Pawn D6 I think is your idea so yeah
they can discover and attack our Rook
but the problem is we can just like play
Rook V8
moving it out of the way and
they can't really make any further
threats
eventually we might try and retake this
Pawn but there's still nothing they can
do about their own Rook
okay another example very similar to
this from a high level game in this
example the player uh David bronstein
with the white pieces did find the right
continuation
D4 Knight F6 C4 G6 this is more of a
king's Indian style defense
and this very opening right is all about
putting the bishop on the long diagonal
you'll see opponents uh do this or maybe
you play this way and it's always
important in these openings to remember
the pressure that this piece exerts and
to keep that in mind as you play and if
your opponent has it to watch out for it
because it can be deadly
but we get to a relatively normal
position and here black decides I'm
going to push forward with C5 I have a
nice Pawn chain I would like to fight
white in the center of the board and
this looks like a very good idea in most
positions this is a very reasonable plan
in this particular one white has a nice
way to punish black for this move
so again always feel free to pause and
try and find the best continuation for
white here
how can we punish black
for overextending slightly and not
taking care of some of the really
important parts of their position
what do you notice
[Music]
uh yes so again we have some really
smart people in the chat here tonight
starting with E5
uh a forcing move right attacking the
Knight forcing it to respond
and the problem that black has is this
is a forcing move so we're making a big
threat you have to deal with this but
after the Knight moves
we have cleared this space for the
bishop and again The Rook is stuck it's
totally trapped you can't block I'll
just take you
it's just gone all the pawns are unable
to do anything
so again a very common trap
um really useful to keep an eye out for
again it's not always you're going to
get the Rook trapped so nicely but
keeping an eye on how we can utilize our
long diagonals how you can use forcing
moves to complement them super super
helpful
okay
uh this one is not going to be so much a
trap but more just kind of a general
game so this one was from 1924 it was
ready versus Yates and in this position
black played the move H6 which was a bit
of a mistake because if you notice white
has a queen on A1 and a bishop on B2
white actually has both of the long
diagonals
this light Square diagonal is kind of
contested between these two Bishops but
we have total dominance here over the
dark Square diagonal a nice battery the
queen is maybe a little inactive but we
can make up for that by putting extra
pressure on this diagonal
um H6 is not so good because black
really had to do something to close this
down and now white can press forward
with the move d4
and we're going to either get control of
E5
or of D4 so if you take for example I
can just play Knight takes this battery
will reactivate at some relevant moment
and cause a lot of problems for black
so instead black tried to close it down
but it's a little too late because now
Knight to E5
attacking too many valuable pieces
basically forcing black to trade
and allowing D takes E5
now we have invaded their position our
Bishop and queen just have a choke hold
over this Pawn so there's nothing you
can do to really fight against it and it
is now exerting pressure into Black's
camp
so just kind of a total dark Square
domination here
um and I'll show these moves because
they can be somewhat instructive at
night backs off to H7 looking I believe
to eventually jump into G5 to reactivate
F4 defending the pawn again allowing
this on passant move if you are not
familiar it is not an illegal move or a
magic trick but if a pawn moves two
spaces obviously on its first turn then
the very next turn if it lands next to
an opponent's Pawn that pawn can act as
if it had only gone one and capture it
this is a real rule
um okay Pawn takes back Knight to G5 but
we just get F4 again
Knight to H3 check King to H1
Pawn to D4
Bishop takes
there's really nothing much else to do
the idea was to maybe open up some
pressure on this diagonal but there's
not really anything you can do Rook from
a to d8 and here ready plays a really
energetic move feel free to look for it
with a pause if you would like but it's
kind of hard to find
um ready plays Rook takes C6 giving up
one of these doubled Rooks in in order
to now gain control over both of these
diagonals
right so after Pawn takes these Bishops
just dominate the board Bishop takes C6
skewering the queen and the Rook uh
Knight to F2 check a bit of an
Intermezzo King to G2 and queen takes
Bishop Queen takes Rook takes
Bishop takes Rook
and when the dust has settled
white has two extra pawns and still a
slight positional Advantage should be an
easy time finding the win the game just
continued in two more moves Rook to D2
King to F3 and here black resigned
there's just too many threats in the
position it's pretty untenable to play
but again we can see the power of
looking for taking control on those long
diagonals those open files
so I think this is a good example let me
share one more on the long diagonals and
then we'll switch over a little bit to
the open files in this position it is
white to move
this one I'll let you take some time and
put kind of your puzzle thinking cap on
and see if you can find the best move
for white keeping in mind how can we use
our long diagonals our open files to
punish our opponents
see what you can find
you can certainly try again don't drink
and drive doctor but
uh yeah it seems like some people are
seeing the right ideas here this king is
very weak even though black is up I
believe the exchange
um our pieces are really primed for this
attack
so how can we make full use of it
uh D7 so are thinking Rook so yeah
Knight D7 is going to Fork
this is not bad but we're we're not
looking just to get some material back
here we're looking to win the game
yeah Knight G6 similarly is going to get
us a fork but
um I believe just King to G8 and black
can try and fight on and survive
probably still not going to be pretty
but yeah Knight G6 is I think fine
there's a lot of good moves here but the
best way is actually there's a force
mate in three
foreign
a few people are starting to see the
idea so I'm going to walk it through
with you so we want to open up this
really beautiful Bishop on the long
diagonal
and the only problem well there's two
problems one are knights in the way two
this Pawn is in the way if this Pawn
were to move by maybe a capture then we
could bring in our Knight somewhere and
make a discovered check and a double
check and try and win the game that way
but if we take with the pawn maybe they
can like push this one and our Pawn is
now in the way so instead Queen takes H6
sacrificing the queen
because now after Pawn takes it is if
you just play here then I can just go
here with mate
so you have to take
Knight to F7 check
our Bishop covers H7 our Bishop is now
activated here so it is a double check
you have no time to take the Knight
King only move is to G8 and now Knight
takes H6 check mate we control all of
the critical squares with our Bishops
and our Knight delivers the killer blow
again only possible because of how much
control our Bishops are exerting on
their King just incredibly powerful
resource here
all right let's look at some open file
examples
in this game uh this is meduna versus uh
palonic in 1979 and black here has some
control over the B file that our Queen
is well placed guarding this B file
maybe we can have ideas of doubling up
and this is actually exactly how black
starts even though the material is equal
we play Rook to B8
uh White plays Bishop to D1 trying to
reduce some of our control of this file
by eliminating the Bishops unfortunately
this is not going to be enough so we
exchange the light squared Bishops and
now we want to invade with our Queen and
make a lot of threats so Queen to B3
attacking A3 and D3
white needs to defend so Rook to A1
holding on to the pawn
and
I'll put this one to you what do you
think black should do here to continue
trying to make progress
material is equal we have pretty
command and control the open file so see
if you can remember when we have an open
file what should our next goal be
it's okay if you don't see the whole
line This is there's a very there's a
lot more to this game but let's just
think one step at a time how do we
improve our pieces and our position
what is the general purpose or one of
the main benefits to having the open
file so Queen to C3 is suggested this is
a really interesting move I think the
problem you might face is if we trade
maybe our Pawn on C3 is going to be too
weak I mean we can play Rook here to
defend but I do think
white will probably be able to forcibly
win that pawn back I'm just not
confident it's going to be safe there
so slightly better is as a few people
are suggesting Queen to B2 one of the
main things we want with the open file
is to invade on the second or seventh
Rank and here we are doing just that
if white takes we can just invade right
away so instead white plays Rook to A2
but we still are happy to make this
trade
because now Black's only heavy piece our
only Rook is still enough on its own to
control this whole file so we invade
with Rook to B3
Rook has to go back to A2 defending this
pawn and notice that our Rook is just
much more active right blacks or sorry
white is stuck on this uh closed file
defending a single Rook Pawn ours is
incredibly active we can move back to
the defense if we have to we can invade
farther and attack this Knight we're
already making several attacks and
multiple threats so our Rook is very
active very powerful
um and now it's just a question
oh yeah just JoJo welcome in thanks for
the rate
um we're talking about open files long
diagonals and how to improve our pieces
so
in this position we decide that our Rook
is doing really well but we need to
punish White's pieces for being so
passive and we need to bring our other
piece into the game
and uh the question is where does this
Knight want to go
I think there's a few kind of candidate
places but one we might consider
I'm not sure exactly where we want it
but the way that black decided to go was
black said I'm going to go Knight to D7
in order to get to B6 in order to get to
A4 and potentially to get to C3 or also
maybe just to control B2
so this night on A4 is going to become a
very powerful piece and this is the plan
so Knight to D7 white White's pieces are
all tied down so they try and activate
the king to try and help
Knight to B6 King to E2 Knight to A4
King to D2 and so the King has joined
The Fray it's just not quite enough
here despite the reduced material uh
White's King is still kind of unsafe and
so actually black finds a really nice
move in this position black actually
plays Rook to B1
with uh a very interesting threat so
let's say white just pushes a pawn here
and tries to stall what is our threat in
this position
what black to move and cause white some
serious problems
okay a lot of people think uh think
Knight C3
and this makes sense to me it's an
excellent Square we're attacking The
Rook but there's actually more than that
what's the idea with Knight C3
yeah yeah you win The Rook so Knight C3
is brutal because we're not just
threatening this Rook but notice that
White's King now having walked close to
our active pieces is put himself in a
lot of danger
our Pawn controls this Square the Knight
Now controls the square The Rook
controls everything on this back Rank
and
there's actually nothing you can do to
save this Rook if you leave it I'm just
going to take it
and the only other safe Square you can't
go to A1 or B2 because of my Rook so the
only safe square is Rook to C2 but you
cannot do that because now the King has
one less square and that one square
makes all the difference with Rook to D1
check mate
so our piece just being so active um
white saw this threat and played uh
instead Knight to C2
but again black is just kind of going to
slowly improve their pieces
and eventually just start winning some
of this material
and
it leads to just kind of a yeah pretty
ending black tries to get some counter
sorry white tries to get some counter
play by sacrificing this Knight and
creating some past pawns it's just not
quite enough and I'm going to show you
the rest of this game just because it's
kind of pretty
but black again sort of traps white in a
mating net even though White's pawns are
very close to promotion
uh White is just in time with Knight to
D1
look to B3 check
ing to H3 and here white to move white
played one more move in Black resign and
the move was F5
controlling G4
kind of freeing up the knight from
having to do that and now the Knight can
jump into G4 followed by Rook to H2
check mate and there's not really a good
answer here
um
if you just yeah push the pawn then this
is basically Unstoppable and if you play
G4 to try and get out of that attack
then Pawn takes King H4
Rook F3 again slowly kind of keeping
this mating and Alive King to H5 King to
G7 again the threat is Rook to H3 and
there's not really anything you can do
so again I I no need to worry too much
about the intricacies of the end of that
game but we saw all the way from the
beginning of this position that we went
from a basically an even game in terms
of material white just or sorry black
just had the benefit of this open file
and really clamped down on it was able
to slowly invade attack a lot of these
weaknesses and make some really good
progress
um okay a few more examples that I think
would be helpful
uh
this is a bit of a kind of puzzle
so it's white to move and using the
benefit of how our Rooks are placed we
can cause some serious problems here for
black
um
see if you can come up with the idea
yeah Dr drink and drive you might be a
little
a little too good for this class you're
picking these up really quick
noticing that our Rook on the G file
attacks this King
and uh we can it's not technically an
open file but because our Rook has been
lifted this is another strategy you can
sometimes use is to uh if you can't get
rid of the pawns you can maneuver your
Rook up and slide it over in order to
take advantage of an attack like this
and in this case that's exactly what's
going on and we notice that with our
Bishop and Rook together we can make
some serious threats against this King
but we can actually start with Rook
takes E2
to lure the queen here and now we see
there is a deadly discovered threat Rook
takes G7
uh King takes Bishop takes and black
resigns because he will be losing the
queen
so just kind of an interesting example
here but I have some that I'm hoping
will be maybe a little more uh
instructive
okay this is a short but sweet one so
notice so this comes from a Park say
versus
michalchison again probably pronouncing
some of these names in 1983
and let's just take a look at this
position and notice that white has
really an excellently placed Queen it's
occupying both the long A1 to h8
diagonal on these dark squares it's also
really nice and centrally placed you
know controlling just good space in
general pieces generally like to be in
the center because they can impact more
of the board and maneuver to which part
of the board they need to but the queen
in general just really loves it
um okay
in the game black here played a mistake
black played Queen to B6 which looks
kind of very natural you know opening up
this Square for The Rook potentially
um looking to start making threats
against White's Castle or even maybe
trying to invade somewhere like this
the problem with this move is it
actually allows the queen to become a
Target
and in a way an accomplice in White's
attack against the black kingdom here
so I'm going to share the first move
here with you in the game white played
Knight to A4 attacking the queen
and let's take a second to see where
this queen can actually go
so not a lot of squares right our Queen
again so centrally placed covers all of
these options you can't go to C5 because
of the night you can't go to either uh
B5 or A6 because of our Bishop
can't go to A5 because of our Queen so
these are all out
so that Lee you can't go to C7 because
of the queen
can't go to d8 because of the Rook
so that only leaves Queen to C6
going to B4
or queen to F2 these are the only safe
squares we can move the queen
if you go to like F2 say we can just
attack it with the Rook
this is not so good I believe this queen
is
I think this queen is trapped
and similarly if you go to B4 we can
just lift this Rook up again
and the queen is not doing so well so in
the game Queen to C6 was the move that
was played
and here
white uh played a really brilliant move
white played Bishop to B5 defended by
the queen
because again we are forcing the queen
now to actually take our Pawn this is
one of the few examples you might see if
someone just willingly giving up a pawn
but actually not just willingly doing it
forcing their opponent to take one of
your pieces other than like a sacrifice
and that's kind of what this is this is
a sacrifice of material this is a Gambit
because now without this Pawn we have
created a semi-open file on the G file
work from H to G1 we're not afraid of
them taking this pawn and just making
another open file
which is what happens Queen takes H2 the
only thing they can really do and now we
just have way too much pressure here
it's white to move and play the best
move so see what you can find
Ted Bradley welcome to the chat I have
seen you in the chat here before and
pumpkin the cat as well
uh welcome back glad to have some
familiar faces here in the chat
um and yes uh the move here is to just
capture on F6 because now with this
semi-open file this Pawn is pinned
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Queen
takes and white wins a piece for two
pawns but also notice that these pawns
were actually kind of in our way without
them we have full rain to just demolish
this King and this game is over
so that is basically all the time we
have but I do want to thank you for
coming into this video series and this
uh lecture tonight
um the kind of takeaway I want to give
you is consider how your pieces are
placed and where you should put them
especially at the beginning
um
but even throughout the course of the
game it's never too late to improve your
pieces and the Bishops and the queen
love these long diagonals or just aiming
towards your opponent's king opening up
files as well for the Rooks invading on
the seventh these are incredibly
powerful tools to add to your Arsenal
and they will help you make a lot of
progress in your chests I certainly hope
so that is the goal here that is all the
time that we have for me but please
stick around as Grandmaster Josh Shang
has a really exciting Grandmasters
Choice lecture coming up so thank you
for coming and hope to see you again
soon
[Music]